Let us continue with our implementation
of linear regression in a neural network
setting. So so far we were working with
a simple model uh with a finite number
of features and uh we were predicting a
continuous output. Uh here we want to
look at a more general case where we
have a highdimensional input with many
features and we are predicting multiple
continuous outputs. We worked with this
in previous machine learning and
statistical learning setups where we
discussed the importance of variable
selection or feature selections and
applying regularization to prevent
overfeeding. So we are going to bring
those concepts that we know in this
setups of neural network and like the
previous lectures this allows us to
apply those techniques in a familiar
setups and later we will use the same
techniques in a more complex
architecture. uh we import the necessary
modules and we set the the seats for
reproduction and then we are going to
write a function that produce a
synthetic data for us that we know it's
ground truth okay so I already wrote the
function it's basically the same uh
Gaussian data generator but here it is a
multivaried Gaussian so the default
setting is it is producing a number of
samples here for example 1,000 sample
and uh with uh a lot of features so here
for example 100 features so we have five
outputs and here I planted um
uh a hint that basically 10 of these
features are uh the most important
features and I want my regularization to
help identify these features. Okay, so
basically this is a multivaried normal.
It has a covariant structure and it will
return the 1,000 observation in this
case of x and y also the true weights of
the linear model. Okay, so let's uh
write down this multi output linear
regression model. We are um initiating
the class and we have the input
dimension, output dimension and
initialization scale or the weights
because in high dimension it's important
where we start the weights and the
default pytor in it might be too large.
So we have the super in it and one
linear layer still without nonlinear
activation because we are still doing
linear regression and this is the
torsion no grad way of initialization of
the parameters. So we add some print
statements and then we will write the
forward method.
So remember the for method returns the
uh the outputs where here we have
multiple outputs. Okay. So let's write
the duct strings
and then return the evaluation of the
linear layer. So with that uh we are
basically done here for the class since
we uh will do the training outside of
it. But like before we are going to add
another method to get the weight stats.
So here we have a lot of weights. We
don't want to print them one by one. So
we are just going to print some
statistics including the the norm of the
weights, mean, standard deviation, max
and some measure of sparity
and we are going to use the
um the following stats. So maybe the
weight norm and
we can add the weight mean
weight
deviation weight mean max and let's just
use max and maybe
the weight sparity
and we have to choose how to do this
one. So the first view we have already
functions. So for the measure of sparity
we are going to count the number of uh
weights that are smaller than some uh
threshold small value over the number of
the entire parameters. With that let's
count the number of
elements that are small and then we
divide it by the entire uh number of
elements in the weight tensor. Okay, so
with that we are going to return the
stats. Okay, so now we want to write a
custom loss. Uh if you remember we had
MSSE before but here I want to include
some regularization penalties
including L2 L1 maybe a elastic net
which is a combination of the two. I
assume that you know these concepts from
before and with that let's write the
class
[Music]
Okay. So let's write init class. Of
course the class uh will uh inherit the
n module. Let's specify this.
Well, so I'm going to add a debugging
message to always lock the
hyperparameters here. With that, we want
to write a forward method that computes
this this regularized class. So we are
writing the forward method. And here I'm
going to change this
and some dictionary here.
So first we have a base MSE loss that we
know how to do it. So uh to compute the
loss um related to the uh L2 and L1 um
we're following the suggestion. Okay,
with that we can write the total loss
which is this. Note that uh we could do
this multiplication here
and uh if it was not because of the
suggestion
and me being lazy I would do that. Let's
write a debugging message that tracks
the individual components and then
return the last and this components. So
now I want to write uh a train training
code. Not only we need this
regularization, we also need to
introduce this validation set that
allows for an unbiased validation of our
predictions. So the nice thing about the
validation set is it helps us to detect
overfeitting early and it helps us to
choose the optimal hyperparameters like
the those lambda values and then decide
when to stop the training. It is one way
of uh avoiding the overfeitting. So
remember that uh sometimes especially in
high dimension where we have small
samples the validation loss is going to
be very high compared to the training
loss. Uh and that shouldn't deter you as
this is uh very natural. Okay. So with
that let's write the function.
and white train.
So, just like before, we're going to
write the uh the data loaders.
Okay. So,
uh then next we need to do the criterion
here
and choose our optimizer which is
already chosen for us. Let's stick with
our SGD for the sake of consistency. We
want to track a few metrics and then we
can write the training loop
for a park in range.
We have that
or the epox stats.
So we have the loss.
Maybe we can even track MSE.
and also the number of batches that are
um so we need this to basically do some
averaging. Okay, we can start the the
batches. You see that already here. So
we have the optimizer
uh that is now zeros. So this is the
forward pass here.
So the output of the criterion if you
remember is the laws and components
which uh takes in this uh batch bread
and batch y and here so we have to
let's check back the criterion which is
this class
here it takes in the nn module
so here okay so we inherit
and an end module and this is basically
a generic module. Later as you saw we
are passing the our own model but a loss
function should be able to work with any
architecture. Okay. So in the forward
pass we are working with the weights. So
here we should
um
um enter the model and here again here
we are going to use the NN module
because we can enter it later right. So
okay so with that
uh here
we only work with weights but this can
include biases too. So we have to make
sure these parameters are only weights
not biases. So I'm confused why I got
this suggestion. So let's go up.
Uh okay. So we didn't initialize the
biases.
Bias is true
by default.
Okay. So now this is okay and
in that case we have to specify here
that we want to only catch the the
weights not biases. Okay. So let's
rewrite this. So we want to sum up these
values only for the weights. So we have
to write an if statement somewhere to
check if the parameter is a weight or a
bias. Okay. So let's start with
and
L1 plus to be zero and then for loop
that goes over the model parameters. But
I also want to want to check if the
parameter is a weight or a bias. So I'm
going to check the name of the parameter
also.
Um
okay so let's see this. Okay this should
be okay. So
okay we prevented an error before
happening which is all always good. So
here even before the backward pass you
can put some checks like for example if
the loss is nan or infinity you can
break the loop. I don't foresee anything
happening here in this linear regression
but for larger uh and more complex
networks you may need to put this checks
for nans or h in losses okay so I'm
going to ask that al let us also track
the the gradient magnitude it
before doing the the step.
Okay. So this is the total norm uh that
is summation of all of these squared uh
norm values and
we can of course do square root of it
and we can append it. So let's do the
append at the end for all of them. Then
we update the parameters update the
epoch stats.
Okay. So that's that. uh we can also add
the validation phase here. So for
validation phase
we want to only evaluate the model. We
are done with the training that is done
over the training data and here for the
validation we are just going to switch
to the eval mode and then with torch no
grad
here uh like I said I don't want to work
on the train I want to work on the
validation so let's do it this way we
are
doing over x val and same criterion.
Okay. So with that let's u record the
matrix which is computed like this. So
for each epoch we want to compute the
the average training loss of that epoch.
Okay. So that's that and then average
training MSE weight norm gradient norm.
Okay. So and then we can add an early
stopping
criteria
wants to check if validation loss is not
decreasing
after like several consecutive epochs.
For example, let's assume if uh after 20
epochs we don't see any improvement, we
can stop the training. So if we have to
have 20 epochs already gone, then here
you see the history validation loss
greater than that.
And since I want
the last 20 not just the last two and
then in that case we print this out. You
can put a if variables here and this
breaks the the training. We can of
course uh continue more verbos uh which
we are going to need
uh later for more complex networks but
I'm going to skip that and I'm going to
just return the the history. Okay. So we
can uh uh generate the data using what
we wrote splitting
what we generated into 80% training and
the rest will be validation.
Uh it's important to standardize the the
data of course here you see that uh we
did the standardization
and it should be separate the train and
uh validation to avoid any leak in our
uh pipeline.
And then here we create the model
and we train the model.
So doing that we see that
the training is stopped at 23. Basically
the first two epochs is enough
and our stopping criteria
uh basically checks and it saw that the
next 20 is basically not improving
anything.
And you see that the validation over the
training MSSE ratio is is pretty good
which shows there is no overfeitting.
And this is the case for a simple linear
regression. But as you see when we move
on to more complex situation the
overfeitting will be very common and uh
we will do that in the next lecture.